[Music]
hey you know we haven't talked about
like for a little bit and i kind of
really really have gotten into it now
with with this guy because one of my new
favorite people who'll be getting more
attention
big gay lion
um
bgo bgl was on some sort of the leo and
danny show i guess i don't know who they
are what was he talking about well the
title of this mark harley on brendan
schaub and dealing with haters
fan fighter and the kid i listened to
yeah i started listening to that podcast
in 2016. yeah so i i your douchebag i
get it and and what about american
russell brand when did he start
listening
when do one of the young bucks
he does look like one of the young are
we sure that that isn't matt jackson it
might be matt jackson i i am not
positive
it's yeah it's an interesting little
like at all
like microcosm there's so much to unpack
as far as the vitriol that it gets
because you know as a most friend ever
since you pointed out how intellectual
yeah yeah there's so much to unpack as
far as the vitriol as far as brendan is
concerned
i hate him no
you're a hater he's talking about you
you hate her all right fine i'm a hater
i hate hate hate um
you do realize like
could you not lean into the character
that i already had you
completely reduced to the moment i laid
eyes on you i mean mark you i know
you've watched the clips of us making
fun oh i know yeah because your google
alerts aren't like exactly exploding
right so i'm sure you have time to check
everything
and
we made fun of you obviously but i right
away after two minutes went so you're
the guy that brandon shaw brought in to
run interference you're the guy brendan
brendan has to appear above it all right
but he's so [ __ ] insecure that he
needs somebody
to be like his little like his outlaws
like tupac had outlaws right so you're
like the outlaws you're you're in here
so you can beef with junior mafia and
brendan can just seem above it all
junior mafia but that's what he is now
here we are you're unappearing this
should be you going let me tell you
about my show let me tell you about what
i do you're on another show making an
appearance and you're doing the [ __ ]
opi [ __ ] haters bro
he's get so many haters he's such a
great guy and he's got beautiful
eyelashes or whatever the [ __ ] and gay
[ __ ] you guys say to each other nice
cast papa nice guys
now by the way when you get a chance i'm
sure you saw nick mullen
and and um and the rest of come down
guys make making fun of them
no
i'll say you know we'll play it on our
show i haven't listened to come down
along well it's worth playing on the
show i'll play it i'll play it maybe
tomorrow of brendan and a good friend of
brian and we're becoming closer i i just
i know brendan is the opposite of a lot
of these things people accuse him of
like number one being
he's he's
what the [ __ ]
hold on
sorry guys i know you're missing mark
harley i apologize there you go generous
and he's
caring so no people will nobody nobody
said brendan's not generous
this is what they do they
they these these la idiots they they go
after the thing that nobody nobody said
brenda's not generous we said he's
stupid
there is a difference accused him of
being narcissistic or i'm like he's he's
like the least exploitative person that
i've probably ever
met or worked with and not funny um yeah
so
i get to see these things doing the
thing now where
you ignore the
the actual like voice is pointing out
you ignore sort of the
uh
you know the criticism that's valid and
then right only pick out you cherry-pick
these like things that nobody
nobody really is saying on a mainstream
level right i think a lot of people are
saying he's a narcissist i'm sure
there's some idiots on the fighter in
the kids subreddit who like
don't understand the [ __ ] definition
of the word narcissist you know and i'm
sure there are people that say all kinds
of wild [ __ ] about him that's we just
call him stupid like roy said how cool
he's just because he's a stupid idiot
with brain damage yeah and he's not very
funny
clips of it to know that like hey the
the people who i care whose opinion i
might care about that would funnel me
towards her special
say it's you know sort of unwatchable
but
um so it's an interesting thing the
douchebag thing i you there was a point
where i would care about people calling
me a douchebag
but you don't care anymore douchebag i
mean dude i mean look look
look man
you're gonna help him out help him out
you do kind of look like a douchebag
right like i mean we're not
it's you know
yeah he's kind of a douchebag it's not
unfair for somebody let's say
to look at you in a grocery store and go
oh what a douchebag
yeah yeah i mean look at your shirt man
you are
like if if this were the end of
ghostbusters
which one
the first one okay not the good one and
told me to choose the form of the
destroyer
and i didn't actually picture anything
in my mind but i just thought of the
word douchebag this guy would appear
a 3 000 foot mark harley would would
descend over manhattan and start
stepping on police cars is what i'm
getting at okay fair enough
you know rebecca what what does that
mean about none of them you're stepping
on police cars you just start screaming
about what a great guy brendan schwab is
like
he's really nice
doesn't really mean much about myself
because it's such a big term too it
usually means something about the other
person that's okay so douchebag is a
vague term so what he needs is nurse
merchants help him out he needs some
more specifics dude it's let's help him
out let's help him out real quick
everything about you this
this all of this
this what you're doing
look at you man
i get it you're all buff i got it you're
probably doing like i don't know let's
see probably like 400 milligrams to test
a week maybe a little bit of trend a
little bit of wind straw you're probably
cutting out for the summer and that's
all [ __ ] good man and also the
propicious hurdles and fallouts as you
can find you have the body uh the lip
injections and the hair
of an extremely insecure douchebag yeah
seriously you look like mickey rourke in
the wrestler so why don't you [ __ ]
calm down i bet you still have jeans and
shirts that still have like the bedazzle
thing in them that you haven't worn in
years but you've hung on to them because
you think it's coming back i bet when
you don't want to throw out all those
bedazzled shirts and jeans i bet when
you go to the gym you wear a big sweater
over your little tiny tank top to get a
pump first before taking the sweater off
right is that what you do
is that what you're doing
huh
do you flex sometimes with your with
your big beats headphones on huh is that
what you do in the mirror just
more crazy mark harley's the kind of guy
that's like wow cheat day and then he
has like one gummy bear yeah exactly
seriously and like some kind of gay
drink like a vodka tonic by the way
douche bag is too fake is that more
specific how about this
you're a remora fish latching on to a
big [ __ ] [ __ ] whale shark that is
brennan jump you know you're gonna sit
and you're holding on to him but in
reality
you tried being a rapper you're not good
at that you tried going to san francisco
clown college whatever the [ __ ]
hey hey
hey he got a certificate sir [ __ ] you
you would have been better off at barber
college
he didn't get a single stormy cloud on
his calendar he got all gold stars
on gold stars nice
sucks so you did that then that didn't
work so you became friends with brendan
and every time you're on a show it's
just you try to push steroids under
brian
is that specific enough for you mark
[Laughter]
you big k lying by the way i agree brian
callan should be honest no i agree too i
want that i want that brian cowan story
arc
right yeah i need those tmz [ __ ]
clips
oh like brian gallon getting a [ __ ]
fight at another bar in la the sunset
last week
[Laughter]
it's a cliche but i'm calling on
steroids
he's the funniest [ __ ] in the world
there'd be so much content from that
scared as i'm gonna have to be around
him bro he would start storming out
every episode like sam tripoli used to
do
on that [ __ ] sports show
jesus holy christ man just seen it in
real time where i'm like
oh i get this collection of a thousand
people because the moment you pop up on
tvk everyone's like this guy sucks
because he's been within three feet of
brendan shaw that's not why i think you
suck bro let me explain something to you
mark carly yes we found you because of
brendan's job but however there were
people that are around brandon's shop
that i think will sasso has done brandon
shop so much time will sass was [ __ ]
hilarious i like him so it's not the
association i like theo vaughn theovan
does his show with brendan i like him
you understand we we could you could
have been introduced to us by [ __ ]
harrison smith and alex stein and had
them both say this guy's a really good
dude and as soon as you all left the
room me and royce would look at each
other and go we hate this guy right
this guy sucks right yeah
yeah you know and um
so it's been interesting seeing like i
know i'm innocent of like a major
wrongdoing you know i didn't that's an
oddity
what an odd thing to say why would you
say that
what a
i'm sorry dj could we run that back i
know we're getting late i got you i got
you i i need
oh i get this collection of a thousand
people because the moment you pop up on
t5k everyone's like this guy sucks
because he's been within three feet of
brenden shop yeah you know and um
so it's been interesting seeing like i
know i'm innocent of like a major
wrongdoing you know i didn't like hurt
these people's feelings in some way
other than just merely existing and so
yeah but that's
but you exist on the internet you want
to make money on the internet so you're
going to get you know the the digital
equivalent of tomatoes thrown at you on
the internet
yep
you get an understanding of that to some
degree just in real life without having
any notoriety
some people just gonna look at me and
not like me that's okay yeah i get to
then also with enough people you get to
be like okay you look like this you look
like this you look like this
and you get to see it really does kind
of play out that i'm like
talking to guys who
don't have a lot going on in their life
and there it is again
hey may i guess can i yes go ahead go
ahead um we are neither engaged in any
organized sports and we are not
currently crushing any puss is that like
there'll be no puss that's being crushed
around these parts
is there a mom's basement in the mix
let's find out okay
bitterness resentment low self-esteem
whatever and i have more subscribers
than you and viewers as well but hey
without brendan jobs that would without
the help of joe rogan's [ __ ] side
piece yeah just know from my timepiece
so if i would never the way they do
online towards training it's hard to
understand it's hard to understand and
me and danny have we go around and we
mess around in public a lot we do these
super kick potty
sorry
pranks we do improv and it's almost so
wow sounds terrible yeah what a life
difficult to get somebody that's just in
shape to be upset at all
is that was that a
what was that about only fat people get
upset i'm sorry trust me there are very
many people who are in shape they get
very very very upset
chris benoit anyone
yeah that guy was ripped and he was
[ __ ] jacked um sir i think you were
trying to dunk on people yeah and
instead you somehow managed to
smash the bridge of your nose against
the rim of the basketball rim and also
somehow make the ball bounce completely
across the other side of the court
just he's just an idiot man
all right man whatever you guys are cool
i guess look we got to stop we're going
over right now i would love to do more
obviously but you know that's about it i
mean you know you you get the the point
you know handsome dudes a pair handsome
dudes never get their feelings hurt it's
what this show should be called i guess
you know what even guys like us that
aren't in shape we still got to go to
the gym too bro yeah rise and grinds
rise and grind [ __ ] say please
please mark carly never stop making
content
never never never stop
and also please mark carly if you're
watching this please please give that
hot head brian callum steroids please
that would push them on him make ever
make sure everyone makes brian callum
feel like he's less of a man unless he
starts doing steroids have people lie
and gaslight him and be like what i'm on
roy's right now
and i need that man on steroids